you know they did win pretty big yes
Madison Kimbrough was at the watch party
excuse me over at Water Street the fans
there couldn't have asked for a better
game too
what a fantastic Monday night here on
Water Street in Henderson as golden
knights fans are in celebration mode as
they pulled out another win for game two
of the Stanley Cup finals I love the
knights and go Knights go Vegas Knights
fans feeling Victorious Monday after
winning game two of the Stanley Cup
finals against the Florida Panthers
fans gathered earlier Monday afternoon
at the Water Street Plaza in Henderson a
perfect spot to watch the game on the
big screen the fan base is great we
always have a good time it's it's great
fun and
the golden knights are amazing and it
was a family affair as most people
brought their kids out to watch too a
huge golden knights fan I'm born and
raised in Vegas my son's middle name is
actually night after the team so Xavier
nine so I mean we're pretty big fans
after the game we asked fans if they saw
this win coming and what their
expectations are for game three on
Thursday and I didn't expect us to win
by that many but I'm glad we did I
expected Vegas to win the fact that they
were able to get this far ahead this
fast and just maintain that lead was
great the golden knights watch party
will continue here at the Water Street
Plaza on Thursday with an expectation
for an even bigger turnout since the
nights will be in Florida battling it
out in game three reporting here in
Henderson Madison Kimbrough 8 News Now